aquí en rosinha la Favela más grande de
Río de Janeiro la mayoría ya han hecho
su apuesta para la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones el ex presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva
bolso no hizo nada por mí al contrario
hizo las cosas más difíciles para las
personas de menores ingresos no mejoro
las cosas Aunque la gente diga que Lula
es un ladrón en los tiempos de Lula
podíamos comprar un televisor
en la primera vuelta Lula ganó en La
Barriada con más del 65% de los votos al
igual que en la mayoría de favelas de la
ciudad como vidigal mareo alemao todo a
pesar de que el estado de Río de Janeiro
es fuertemente bolsonarista al final la
gente pasa hombre y solo los pobres
ayudan a los pobres Y es que las favelas
como rosina son un reflejo del perfil de
los votantes del ex mandatario de
izquierdas ya que según la última
encuesta de datafoya los más pobres las
mujeres los afro y los más jóvenes se
decantan por el líder del partido de los
trabajadores estamos pagando nueve
dólares por un kilo de carne con tres
piezas y van a votar por bolsonaru en
serio es Lula l bolsonaro tiene apoyos
en las favelas pero su popularidad ha
por su gestión de la pandemia y el
repunte del hambre factores que
empujaron a personas como Antonio dos
Santos peluquero de rosiña ha decantarse
por Lula en estas elecciones a pesar de
haber votado por bolsonaro en el 2018
claro
el tipo parecía que se tomaba la
pandemia en broma
niños muriendo mujeres perdiendo a sus
maridos hombres perdiendo a sus esposas
y a él no le importaba
ahí durante su campaña Lula ha prometido
a los pobres como la mayoría de la
población de rosina que alejará el
hambre de sus vidas